[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
والله دافي امنياتي اول شيء الحمد لله
يعني عام راح وعام جاي ان شاء الله هذا
اول شيء وثاني شيء والله الاهداف انه يعني
الواحد بيطور نفسه يعني من سنه سنه ان شاء
الله والامنيات ان شاء الله انه بنكبر
يعني سواء علميا عمليه باذن الله ان شاء
الله بنطلع العام الجديد ان شاء الله باذن
الله وكمان بالنسبه للتوقيت يعني جداول
كده
هدف جدا مهم صغري وانا يلا ان شاء الله
باذن الله السنه الجايه السنه الجايه اني
انا احاول يعني اخذ الجزء او اخذت من جزر
كده بسيط من القران ان شاء الله
الاولاد نكون ان شاء الله صالحين وان شاء
الله يتفوقوا في دراستهم ونشوفهم بعيوننا
ان شاء الله مستقبلهم امن في البلاد هذه
وجميع البلاد
من الاخر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اتمنى في العام الجديد ان شاء الله اني
اطور نفسي انظم وقتي همم
يعني في اهداف عندي خطط ان شاء الله انها
تتحقق واتمنى ان شاء الله همم يعم
بالسلامه والامن على الجميع ان شاء الله
تنظيم الوقت اول شيء همم
تنظيم الوقت مع العائله ومع العمل وكده
يعني هذه اهم الاشياء الواحد
الجديد
حياه جديده وسنه جديده ان شاء الله باذن
الله ويحفظ لي امي
ههه تمام دي ريال مدريد ده رقم واحد يعني
في الحياه